allez pousser vous
écartez vous
[Musique]
allez le public est dehors en train
d'attendre
je le mets de ce côté là
je n'arrive pas à croire qu'il va se
marier mon dieu mais mon portable je
pourrais le prendre quand je serai sur
l'éléphant nature
je comprends
demain
bonne chance dans edge est un
[Musique]
prince indien s'avance vers son destin
il a 25 ans et porte les mêmes habits de
mariage que son arrière grand père il
est plus beau que le prince william
en inde le conte de fées existent encore
et nous allons vous le faire vivre un
rêve éveillé aux côtés des dernier
maharadja et de leurs héritiers comme le
prince d'année geessink sept jours de
cérémonies grandioses pour le mariage du
siècle auxquels nous avons été invités
exceptionnellement
c'est mon rêve d'avoir un mariage comme
ça et qu'un prince and me chercher sur
un éléphant
sur le magnifique la bouteille pour un
jeune prince business man nous a ouvert
les portes des plus beaux palais du
monde sa famille en possède 10 ce sont
aujourd'hui des hôtels de luxe où les
stars américaines viennent se reposer le
prince d'udaipur vend du rêve et c'est
une affaire qui marche
mais lille
le maharadja du troisième millénaire
font le grand écart entre modernité et
tradition séculaire le plus jeune de ces
rois à 13 ans il va à l'école mais le
week end il vit entouré de ses quatre
son serviteur
nous allons découvrir ses fastes d'un
autre temps et les secrets de cette
machine à rêves une plongée exclusif
dans les coulisses des plus grandes
familles indiennes
le rajasthan le pays des rois
cet état du nord de l'inde a été façonné
par les maharadjahs leurs alliances et
les guérillas qu'ils se sont libres et
ont rythmé l'histoire de la région
aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus droit de vie
et de mort sur leur sujet mais les
villages vivent encore dans l'ombre de
leur pouvoir et de leur somptueux palais
celui de kim char a été construit au
xvième siècle et appartient à la même
dynastie depuis toujours il s'apprête à
accueillir pendant une semaine l'un des
plus grands mariages de son histoire un
mariage traditionnel avec une pointe de
modernité
et ça à quoi ça sert la famille du
maharadja vu s'ouvrir au monde elle a
fait appel au savoir-faire américain et
à cet homme puneet ses parents sont
indiens mais il a toujours détenu aux
états unis vous dites est un peu stressé
les codes d union indienne il ne les
connaît pas vraiment à vrai dire je ne
sais pas trop ce qu'il va se passer
pendant cette cérémonie en leur genre
promise
président s'est entouré d'une équipe
internationale des américains une
française olivia créatrice
la première fois qu'elle est venu en
inde olivia des 22 ans elle n'est jamais
repartie
dans la houppe aujourd'hui elle parle
parfaitement le hindi et réalise ses
rêves se fait logique oui ça fait 12 ans
que chez l'un d'eux même un peu plus
duriez plus assumer qu'il a au fond d'un
jardin dont la carte blanche on peut on
peut se lâcher comme y attendent invités
on peut faire les choses en grand en
fait
en france ça serait quand même j'imagine
qu'il ya plus de 2 de choses codeo qu'on
peut pas faire là on peut un peu cela
chez les couleurs les idées les petits
cadeaux les petits machins aussi par
rapport au budget si on permet de faire
beaucoup plus de choses que j'ai
beaucoup plus de démesure oui beaucoup
plus et puis ils demandent que ça aussi
donc c'est ça qui est sympa
le budget plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros le montant exact
restera secret ici tout est possible la
main d'oeuvre ne coûte pas cher pour
quelques euros par jour des dizaines de
villageois sont réquisitionnés près de
400 hôtes de marque sont attendus pour
une semaine de fête cette déjeuner et 7
dîner préparé par les plus grands chefs
du pays
les privilégiés seront logés dans le
palais aux frais du maharadja pour
accueillir les autres invités les
organisateurs ont imaginé une oasis sur
le sable des centaines de tentes sont
installées
tout le confort en plein désert
on rentre par là comme ça voilà donc
elles sont super
la salle de bain ça c'est le donc le
robinet avec une vaste qui sera rempli
vous avez qu un petit village blood on
the way on recrée un village ouais on
est coupé du monde donc ça c'est assez
sympa on est entouré de on a entouré du
nom qu'on n'a pas le bruit l'extérieur
et puis on aura un plafond des toiles
donc ça va être sublime
au même moment au village la famille
royale offre un banquet ce géant pour
remercier les villageois de leurs
efforts trente mille retard
[Musique]
bonjour comment allez vous ça fait
longtemps qu'on ne s'est pas vu j'espère
que vous allez bien en cinq siècles rien
n'a changé les hommes viennent saluer
l'héritier lui glisse un cadeau dans la
main un billet de 100 roupies soit 1
euro 50 une somme dérisoire pour la
famille royale mais presque un jour de
salaire pour eux c'est juste un geste
symbolique
comme ils viennent à la réception il
nous offre un petit cadeau ce manga
non
et voici le maharadja en personne gage
and racing le père de dan angie pendant
quatre siècles ses ancêtres ont régné
sans partage sur toute la région les
villageois touche ses pieds en signe de
respect comme s'il était toujours leur
maître ait eu ces sujets
d'après moi ce banquet c'est la
cérémonie la plus importante du mariage
ici ce sont nos racines nous appartenons
à ce village depuis vingt générations
nos amis nos proches sont importants
mais le peuple c'est le plus important
il faut dire que ces villageois sont
aussi ses électeurs gagen racines comme
beaucoup d'autres maharaja s'est engagé
en politique il est aujourd'hui ministre
de l'énergie du rajasthan
dans la foule un groupe de touristes
français arrivé par hasard au milieu du
banquet
d'où venez vous
je connais la france je suis allé en
alsace
à mulhouse très exactement au musée de
l'automobile
pour eux aussi les maharaja père et fils
se montre accessible
voilà à
vous pensez de tout surtout
obsolète un peu louis xiv avait
l'impression d'aller à la couronne
le peuple vient nous l'a dit en plus roi
et la reine cet argent
mirobolants des pensées et quand on a un
tout petit peu plus loin que les gens
n'ont pas de vie dans la crasse et dans
la misère la bassée ils ont fait la
révolution française
un seigneur qui entretient la fidélité
de son peuple grâce à quelques assiette
de riz l'ancien système féodal n'a pas
complètement disparu
même si les maharaja ont dû se mettre au
travail
[Musique]
et là bas c'était le palais des moussons
ma famille y déménager au moment de la
mousson
c'était l'un des points les plus élevés
la pluie faisait monter le niveau des
autres jusqu'au pied de la colline on
aurait dit que le palais volée c'est mon
grand père qui a converti le lake palace
en hôtel à la fin des années 60 et
ensuite il a fait de même avec les
autres hôtels
pourquoi avez-vous il besoin de faire ça
et bien pour maintenir en état tout
c'est énorme bâtisse parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce serait un défi de le
faire soi même pour des raisons
économiques les temps ont changé
et cela vous pose problème d'avoir
transformé ses palais en hôtel pas du
tout partagé sa maison c'est un
sentiment fantastique
l'achat rage suit les traces de son père
maharajah reconverti en homme d'affaires
il gère les dix palace hôtel de la
famille aujourd'hui il doit se rendre
dans l'un d'eux pour superviser les
préparatifs d'un mariage
[Musique]
d'abord ils vont entrer par là puis
aller dans le jardin là bas ils
s'échangeront les colliers de fleurs en
musique
ensuite en tirera les feux d'artifice et
la procession commencera
le prince s'est exilé le temps de ses
études il est parti en australie pour
apprendre les métiers de l'hôtellerie au
retour un empire l'attendait mais il a
fait ses armes là bas ils n'oublient pas
ce qu'il a appris le souci du détail
c'est la décoration définitive
le premier travail que j'ai fait c'était
lors d'un grand banquet pour 600
personnes en australie ma première vraie
expérience
j'assurais le service du petit déjeuner
je me souviens je devais porter cette
verre de soda je n'aurais jamais imaginé
ce qui allait se passer j'ai fait une
chute devant les invités ça a été le
plus grand désastre de mario
plus à l'aise en homme d'affaires qu'en
serveurs l'héritier du trône d'udaipur
se déplace en voiturette de golf
il est ici chez lui
un tiers de la vie lui appartient dont
le très prestigieux city palace
construit au xvième siècle par ses
ancêtres c'est le plus grand palais
forteresse du rajasthan 500 mètres de
long sur 30 mètres de haut il surplombe
la ville
c'est là qu'ils habitent même si une
partie du palais a été converti en hôtel
5 étoiles il y à 40 ans
30 chambres au charme d'antan dont le
prix ne dépasse pas 200 euros un luxe
abordable qui fait le succès des palace
hôtel de la famine xing
outre la vue inoubliable
rosa
c'est bon tout est sous contrôle tout le
monde est prêt en mode rock'n'roll
oui on a deux événements aujourd'hui et
pour lundi tout est en ordre
autour de la table les membres du
conseil d'administration
ils se retrouvent une fois par semaine
dans la salle de réception du ctpa là
sous l'oeil des illustres aïeux de la
ccia rage même si l'héritier aimerait
que l'ambiance soit un peu plus
rock'n'roll il doit composer
vous êtes très jeune vous avez 27 ans
vous avez beaucoup de responsabilités
est ce que ce n'est pas parfois un peu
pesant
parfois c'est un peu pesant c'est sûr je
ne vais pas vous mentir et vous dire que
tout est fantastique tout le temps même
si parfois ça peut le paraître mais
j'essaie de garder la tête froide j'ai
comme tout le monde des moments où je
n'en peux plus mais on fait avec après
c'est une fonction très prenante comme
beaucoup de choses dans la vie si
j'avais une échoppe et que je vendais du
ces se serait prenant aussi le style
être fils de maharaja n'est pas toujours
une sinécure
la ccia rage comme les autres princes a
quitté sa famille dès l'enfance pour
recevoir la meilleure éducation
m
les jeunes héritiers sont envoyés aux
maillots college une atmosphère austère
et mystérieuse ligne de poudlard l'école
de harry potter
6 heures du matin
réveil pour les élèves
ils sont un petit millier la crème de
l'élite indienne ils ont en commun
d'avoir des parents très aisée et le
plus riche d'entre eux s'est lui pas de
madame singh il n'a pas encore 13 ans et
il est déjà maharaja à la tête d'une
fortune de 500 millions d'euros
ici tout le monde est soumis au même
régime qu'importe les origines et les
titres
j'ai pas envie de me lever
padmanabh apprend à vivre en
collectivité
sans ces quatre son serviteur
[Musique]
il y a des jours où vous n'avez pas
envie de vous réveiller
oui
mais on est obligé
et ça fait combien temps vous êtes là
deux ans c'est ma troisième année c'est
vous qui avez choisi de venir ici non ce
sont mes parents qui voulais m'inscrire
ici
avant lui ses cousins son grand père son
arrière-grand-père sont passés par cette
école le collège a été créé pour éduquer
les fils de roi en 1875
à cette époque les jeunes princes vive
est ici entouré de leurs domestiques
jusqu'à 300 pour certains
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui pas de
malade est traité comme n'importe quel
étudiant
tous les matins il enchaîne course à
tulle et gymnastique et sans traitement
de faveur
quand il est arrivé à l'école ses
parents ont demandé qu'il soit traité
comme n'importe quel autre évêque qu'il
devait suivre le cursus classique et
devenir un bon étudiant donc aucune
faveur n'ont aucune faveur
et puis la question ne se pose pas
puisqu'il n'en demande aucune
c'est juste un étudiant parmi les 830 du
collège
quand il est arrivé ici padmanabhan a
dit à personne qu'il était marin indien
l'estrade je pensais si je leur dis ils
vont se moquer de moi
je pensais que c'est ce qui arriverait
mais en fait ils sont gentils avec moi
mais pour quoi pensiez-vous cela
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas comme eux
disons que enfin j'avais peur qu'il me
mette à l'écart
maintenant je ne peux plus faire de
bêtises
c'est à dire je ne peux plus dire du mal
des gens
si je le fais non seulement je serai
renvoyé mais en plus ça ce ne serait pas
bon pour la réputation de ma famille
vous avez plus de pression
non pas plus de pression mais plus de
responsabilités
aujourd'hui l'école forme les futurs
avocats les chefs d'entreprise les
politiciens padmanabh voudrait faire des
études de droit mais pour le moment il
essaie d'être un garçon comme les autres
ils partagent les mêmes passions que ses
copains comme le football
aujourd'hui le fait qu'il soit un
maharaja ne change rien à notre amitié
parce qu'on et ses amis ses bons amis et
on oublie qu'il est roi c'est tout
est ce que le fait d'être un roi se
redonne quelques avantages
je ne sais pas tu es trop jeune pour
savoir ça
pour savoir quoi bomber rendre compte si
ça m'avantage ou pas vous ne voulez pas
le savoir non
[Musique]
pas de mal à ben c'est que son destin
lui échappe sans remonter vos
chaussettes
pourtant il s'en est fallu de peu pour
qu'il ne soit jamais maharaja l'histoire
sulfureuse de ses parents a bien failli
lui coûter le trône c'est ce que nous
allons découvrir
hakim chars pas de scandale tout se
passe comme prévu pour le moment au
sixième jour de fête le prince se rend à
la cérémonie des cadeaux
sa mère accueille la famille de sa
future belle-fille
par ce mariage arrangé
c'est l'union de deux clans qui essaient
dé la mariée elle est absente elle reste
caché jusqu'au dernier moment
toutes les familles de la caste des
rajput sont invités des descendants de
maharaja devenu businessman banquiers
avocats signe des temps des amis
étrangers du prince ont été conviés
mais vous connaissez le prince
oui
et quelles sont vos premières
impressions
c'est incroyable d'être là
personnellement c'est la première fois
que je vis en inde c'est génial de
pouvoir partager ce moment avec
sept à lausanne qu'elles ont connue d'un
angie quand il était étudiant à l'école
hôtelière mais aucun de ses camarades ne
savait alors qu'il était prince
non
on trouvait donc
très
commun
quand on l'a connu il était comme les
autres il sortait avec nous vous
entraîner à 10 dans une chambre on
devait débrouiller tout seul faire notre
ménage nous mêmes et là tout le monde
est là sa disposition et il est
tellement sérieux
il est beau mon fils à son tour de
suisse il était gros il a perdu 37 kg il
a une autre allure maintenant
à l'école hôtelière je mangeais de la
fondue de la raquette
du coup je me suis dit qu'il fallait que
je retrouve la forme et je me suis mis à
courir
maintenant il va courir après sa femme
ce jour là dan angie va recevoir des
centaines de cadeaux
de simples fruits secs ou des objets de
grande valeur transmis dans les familles
de génération en génération
salvat pas concernés
ce sont des bijoux et un sabre
on respecte la tradition râches août à
la lettre
comment vous sentez-vous là maintenant
bien lieu
j'ai encore du mal à réaliser vous
cachez vos émotions
disons que mes amis me demandent si je
suis nerveux et je leur dis que pour
l'inscription va bien
le point rouge à politika est posé sur
le front de d'alger
son destin est désormais lié à la
famille de sa future femme
ça vous donne envie d'épouser un point
qu'ils y aillent qui ne donnera pas
envie de marquer une plainte
on est là pour ça on cherche
d'un angie lui n'est plus libre le pacte
entre les deux familles vient d'être
conclu il va pouvoir aller chercher son
épouse qui l'attend dans son palais abu
d'éléphant
[Musique]
c'est le meilleur temps pour voler le
ciel est clair
le prince d'udaipur entend bien profiter
encore quelques temps de sa vie de
célibataire
ce samedi il nous a conviés sur
l'aérodrome privée de la famille pour
partager son loisir préféré
l'aéromodélisme auquel il consacre
plusieurs heures par semaine ça vous
arrive de casser des avions oh oui j'en
ai cassé quelques-uns des avions
mais peu importe une équipe technique
assurent les réparations et les
encouragements
tout pour le bonheur du prince
[Musique]
belle atterrissage majesté
c'est vraiment relaxant presque
thérapeutique
il faut être concentré à 100% pour
piloter donc il n'y a pas le choix il
faut absolument oublier tout le reste ou
sentais un peu comme un enfant parfois
ça passe parfois toujours
un grand enfant qui ne collectionne pas
les petites voitures mais les luxueux
cylindres est
[Musique]
celle d'un autre temps d'une époque où
seuls les maharaja et les colons
britanniques pouvaient se déplacer et
parader dans de tels bolides
ces voitures ont été commandés en même
temps il y en avait une pour mon
grand-père la décapotable à gauche et la
noire était pour ma grand mère
celle-ci est différente à cette époque
la reine n'avait pas le droit très
exposée aux regards du public donc la
voiture était fermée et les vitres
fumées
là bas c'est la phantom qui a été
utilisée dans le film de james bond
tourné à udaipur si vous regardez le
film vous l'apercevrez
cadillac du début du siècle fantômes et
rolls royce la famille possède une
vingtaine de véhicules de collection de
temps en temps l'acce marage fait un
petit tour dans les rues d'udaipur ils
appellent ça son bain de foule
les gens sont surpris de vous voir dans
votre voiture oui ça les surprend car
ils peuvent me voir dans cette
décapotable c'est une manière pour moi
de me sentir plus proche d'eux et pour
eux de se sentir plus proche de moi
une jeunesse dorée mais à quel prix
difficile pour le prince héritier
d'udaipur de sortir du chemin tracé par
sa famille il est l'ultime rejeton de
s'aligner une responsabilité qu'il doit
assumer chaque jour
le palais de ses ancêtres a été
transformée en musée tout ici lui
rappelle ses devoirs
premier d'entre eux faire un bon mariage
et
vous allez devoir épouser une rage qui
il faut toujours qu'on me pose des
questions sur ce sujet
eh bien oui se marier à l'intérieur de
la communauté c'est quelque chose que
l'on fait depuis 400 ans donc ça doit
continuer comme ça
c'est une des valeurs essentielles de
notre royaume
et j'y suis très attaché donc vous
n'êtes pas celui qui changera sa
disons que je préférerais ne pas être
celui qui changera sa
un mariage arrangé pour perpétuer la
dynastie c'est l'obsession des
maharadjahs le seul moyen de continuer à
exister d'être légitime selon
dès l'enfance les princes sont élevés
selon ses principes et ceux qui dérogent
risque gros
l'été s'est installé à jaïpur la
capitale du rajasthan dont le petit
maharaja est roi il est en vacances et
se prépare dans ses appartements
aujourd'hui c'est son anniversaire il a
13 ans il est attendu sur le trône royal
au palais c400 serviteur sont rassemblés
pour l'occasion
parmi eux les aides de camp un nom
français hérités de la période coloniale
pour désigner la gare de rapprocher du
prince il y en a 16 leurs titres et leur
fonction se transmettent de père en fils
le col doit être soit fermé sinon c'est
impoli
à l'arrivée du maharadja nos tenues
doivent être impeccable jusque dans le
moindre détail c'est pour ça qu'il
réajuste son col
et l'un d'entre vous est chargé de
vérifier des tenues
oui c'est notre doyen c'est lui qui nous
rappelle à l'ordre et nous met à
l'amande si on n'est pas parfaitement à
billets si quelque chose manque il le
remarque tout de suite
mes ancêtres travaillais déjà pour le
roi moi je travaille pour le roi et
monfils travaillera pour le roi c'est
une affaire de famille pourquoi cette
tradition est si importante pour nous
parce qu'on veut maintenir ce système
qui est notre héritage on ne veut pas
être moderne enfin on veut bien un peu
de modernité mais tout en maintenant
notre système social
un système qui fait vivre beaucoup de
monde toute une cour entoure son protégé
le dernier de la dynastie
depuis la fondation du royaume en 1033
quarante quatre générations de maharaja
se sont succédé
je m'assois la wii votre majesté
padmanabh apprend à reproduire les
gestes de ses illustres prédécesseurs
tous les hommes de la cour viennent
présenter leurs respects aux jeunes
maharaja il lui touche les pieds et lui
offre quelques pièces de monnaie
les caméras du palais ne perdent rien de
ce défilé un terminal
[Musique]
il lui donne de l'argent pas de l'argent
c'est un signe de respect
après le roi va le donner aux pauvres et
vous
et où sont vos amis
ils sont invités à la fête après
[Musique]
autrefois les aides de camp et des le
maharadja gouverner aujourd'hui ils sont
plutôt des éléments de décor le
principal conseiller de pâtes mana c'est
son père ce n'est pas trop de pression
pour lui si bien sûr il est seulement
dans sa quatorzième année donc ils
doivent ressentir de la pression
il s'en tire plutôt bien vous êtes fier
de lui
narines racing ne pensais pas qu'un jour
son fils deviendrai maharajah lui même
n'a jamais c'était prince il est entré
dans la famille royale de jaïpur par
effraction et a plongé dans un autre
monde par amour
c'est le parrain de mes deux enfants
voilà mon fils mais pour ma fille
c'est le prince charles oui le prince
charles
et là c'est le président clinton lui
aussi est venu plusieurs fois ici
le prince charles est un habitué du
palais de jaïpur il est d'abord venu
avec lady di puis avec camilla les deux
familles sont très proches
la reine racing n'aurait jamais dû être
sur la photo quand il était jeune il
était chauffeur au service de la
princesse fils du maharadja et ils sont
tombés amoureux une histoire à la roméo
et juliette qui a fait scandale
la famille royale reste discrète sur
cette affaire mais dans les sous-sols du
palais les archives parle
enfin ce sont surtout les archivistes
qui sont bavards intarissable sur la
dynastie de jaïpur et l'incident qui est
venu gâcher un sens pur depuis un
millénaire
une princesse de jaïpur se doit
d'épouser un prince ils n'étaient pas
prince
plus tard il a été accepté et anobli
mais au début ils n'étaient pas
acceptées du tout au début non que
disaient les gens
que pensait-il à cette époque ça faisait
la une des journaux ils ont parlé
partout dans la presse
oui ça fait un gros scandale dans la
communauté rajput
personne ne s'attendait à ce qu'elle
épouse quelqu'un qui lui étaient
inférieures socialement
et voici les thèses de la même caste
mais pas du même rang
et la princesse a dit ça m'est égal oui
ça m'est égal
elle a été très courageuse et oui il lui
a fallu beaucoup de courage
le petit padmanabh fruit de l'union
entre une princesse et un chauffeur ne
pouvait pas selon la tradition accéder
au trône
pourtant lorsque le roi son grand père
meurt en 2011 c'est lui qui est convoqué
pour brûler ses cendres à 12 ans il
hérite du titre de maharajah
pour en arriver là la famille a dû ruser
m
oh
au palais de kim chars les festivités se
poursuivent en fanfare toujours en
l'absence de la future mariée rester
dans son palais
personne n'a encore vu son visage à part
la famille proche c'est à dire ceux qui
l'ont choisi en l'occurrence la mère de
dan angie
elle ne résiste pas à l'envié de nous la
présenter sur son téléphone portable
j'ai une photo de la future mariée
regardez dans le système rajput de
gaulle la fille se propose comme
prétendante en envoyant sa photo c'est
la fille qui établit le premier contact
et après si on aime la photo on voit
la princesse s'appelle mirguet chat elle
vient du gujarat un état voisin du
rajasthan une princesse de la castre h
pour elle aussi c'est le critère absolu
pour que le mariage soit possible je ne
comprenais pas quand j'étais jeune et
que ma mère me parlait de la ligne mais
maintenant je comprends que mon fils
représente la 20e génération est
aujourd'hui notre son épure si on se
marient hors de la caste après le son
est mêlé et là toute la ligne et est
terminée
le moment d'aller chercher la mariée
approche c'est l'effervescence
[Musique]
on compte dognin tous mes amis des
turbans et des séries on va leur
apprendre comment les matches
ça va être très cool
il faut juste que je fasse attention à
ce que rien ne dépasse
j'ai vraiment hâte d'être au mariage et
de voir tout ça
beaucoup loi c'est la première fois que
vous portez un turban oui
j'espère le turban ce sont sept mètres
de tissu a enroulé autour de la tête
voyons voir ça c'est les couleurs arc en
ciel
c'est un peu lourd toujours que ce que
je pensais mais c'est sympa on joue le
jeu comme ça
il y à quelques siècles la cour du roi
serait parti chercher la mariée à cheval
mais aujourd'hui ses valises à roulettes
et bus climatisé direction jaïpur à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de là
où la princesse demeure six heures de
route les attendent
nous avons choisi de rester à kiel chars
avec les femmes de la famille je baisse
la lumière
il nous reste 10 minutes
selon la tradition les femmes
n'assistent jamais à la présentation de
la mariée est d'habitude elle s'ennuie
mais nous sommes en 2012 et cette fois
on va s'occuper d'elle
bonité olivia les organisateurs du
mariage leur ont préparé une soirée
spéciale très glamour d'où vous est
venue l'idée de cette soirée casino
j'adore james bond et je me disais que
c'était une manière originale d'échapper
aux festivités classique des mariages de
sortir des habitudes je voulais proposer
aux femmes quelque chose à faire de
drôles
d'habitudes elle des jeunes puis elle
dîne en attendant que les festivités
soit fini
ouais et sont dans l'ascenseur je me
prépare nous habiter ouais les premières
femmes sont en bas et donc moi je les
accueille avec une fleur
je suis préparé en deux minutes ah ça y
est c'est parti
dans la tradition rajput les femmes sont
voilées pour se cacher du regard des
hommes
ce soir elles vont troquer leur voile
contre des accessoires de charme
g
oya rajoelina vous êtes parfaite
devriez peut-être accrocher cette fleur
argentine elles sont un peu confuses au
début mais finalement ça leur plaît elle
adhère à l'idée c'est bien
je suis en acheter les boas les choses
comme ça quand je connais bien les
bazars et je passe ma vie à acheter des
choses à faire du sourcing comme on dit
donc j'ai aussi aidé époux dit
le diriger ou à acheter quel type de
choses données des quelques idées
rajouter des touches de couleurs
la reine a tout de suite accepté l'idée
de pougny t olivia
c'est elle qui voulait apporter cette
touche de modernité à ces noces très
codifié
oui regardez j'ai pris mon argent
car ce soir elles vont flamber
un casino a été aménagé au palais pour
elle blackjack roulette pour la première
fois de leur vie elle goûte aux démons
du jus
la soeur et la mère de daniel g ont
réussi leur pari
dans nos communautés les mariages sont
toujours pareil alors pour changer un
peu et pimenter les choses on a fait ça
et je crois que ça marche que les filles
aiment ça et s'amuse ce qui était notre
objectif
des princesses déchaîner sur la piste
l'unité olivia sont surpris par le
succès de cette soirée jamais ils n'ont
vu ces femmes dans c'est comme ça
non
je crois que les choses changent mais
les valeurs restent les mêmes
on retrouve ça dans la nature humaine
mais aussi dans les familles royales
c'est beau de voir les choses évoluer
mais c'est beau aussi de voir à quel
point ils sont attachés à leur identité
et à leur culture
vous êtes content de cette soirée tant
que mes clients sont contents je suis
content aussi
une soirée survoltée alors qu'hadji pour
la cérémonie finale du mariage se
prépare dans une toute autre ambiance
c'est ce que nous verrons le lendemain
[Musique]
le mélange tradition modernité c'est ce
qui fait le succès des dynasties
d'aujourd'hui le prince d'udaipur
n'hésite pas à enfiler son survêtement
pour une partie
si la balle bien sûr moi je vous
préviens je la laisse passer
simplicité et décontraction tout pour
séduire ses fans qui se sont déplacés
pour suivre son entraînement le prince
est une célébrité locale
joue vraiment très bien la semaine
dernière c'était le meilleur marqueur la
rencontre
c'est une icône ici on a eu
tous les jeunes regardent ce qu'il fait
il joue pour pouvoir limité
on essaie de copier son style de jeu
les gens ici aiment bien venir le voir
jouer il est comme une star we sing star
sur le terrain il oublierait presque ses
fonctions et sa retenue princière mais
dans les tribunes il est le seul à
s'asseoir sur le canapé
brolin
ses serviteurs sont un peu plus loin
toujours aux petits soins
même le ketchup est servi dans une
saucière en argent
[Musique]
comment vous sentiez-vous sur le terrain
très chaud
vous auriez pu être un professionnel de
cricket
oui j'aurais pu être professionnel mais
j'ai fait un choix différent mais grand
passionné des swaps ibl doublé j'ai
préféré donner l'opportunité à des
jeunes de jouer
soit je faisais une carrière moi-même
soit gd les jeunes et j'ai préféré de
son père abbé surtout d'autres ambitions
pour lui le seul fils de la famille les
photographes sont aux aguets la ccia
rage se retrouvent régulièrement dans
les magazines people avec ses conquêtes
successives
[Musique]
ce qui n'est pas du tout du goût de sa
famille
il refuse de commenter ces images et de
parler de sa vie privée
l'héritier d'udaipur veut faire
comprendre qu'il est rentré dans le vent
à vrai dire il n'a pas trop le choix
son père maharaja en titre d'udaipur
depuis 30 ans a accepté de nous recevoir
lors d'un cocktail qu'il donnait sur la
terrasse privée de son palais
tout ce que je lui demande c'est de ne
pas dilapider l'héritage
c'est très tentant de tuer la poule aux
oeufs d'or comme l'ont fait beaucoup de
maharaja il s'amène nul pas
valu les valeurs elles ne changeront pas
et c'est pour cela que nous devons
soigner notre image maintenant l'esprit
d'entreprise a toujours fait dominer
chez nous c'est ancré en lui il faut
faire fructifier ses affaires
a toujours été comme ça chez
autrement dit un bon mariage c'est bon
pour les affaires
pas question de perdre ses privilèges le
fils suivra le choix du patriarche
[Musique]
qu'arrive-t-il à ceux qui bravent les
interdits à ceux qui osent les mariages
d'amour à jaïpur dans le palais du jeune
prince le calme est revenu après la
tempête causée par le mariage de ses
parents il ya 15 ans
padmanabhan rendez vous avec son
tailleur tous les trois mois il grandit
vite il faut sans cesse ajuster ses
vêtements
[Musique]
m
vous souvenez vous de la première fois
où vous avez porté un costume royal non
vous étiez trop petit oui et vous vous
souvenez de sa première fois oui il
avait trois ans et il n'a pas aimé du
tout
la cause du col qui le gênait
alors il pleurait il pleut et
ses essayages sont un moment de
complicité entre le père et le fils
enfin entre le fils et son père
biologique
car officiellement padmanabh est le fils
de son grand père celui ci l'a adopté
quand il avait 5 ans
en 2003 il y a eu une grande cérémonie
au palais il y avait beaucoup d'invités
c'était la cérémonie d'adoption
est officiellement ma femme et moi avons
remis notre fils à ces nouveaux parents
qui étaient donc ses grands parents
[Musique]
et ce jour là il est devenu leur fils
depuis nous n'avons plus de droits sur
lui il est sous l'autorité de ces
nouveaux paraître c'est leur fils
en adoptant padmanabh son grand père lui
a donné un rang 1 100 royal et fait
taire les mauvaises langues vous vous
souvenez de la dernière fois où vous
avez élevé la voix sur votre fils
ça oui parce que c'est encore un bébé
malgré tout
mais bon je me souviens de la dernière
fois on allait jouer au tennis
et je roulais qu'il s'échauffait mais il
refusait de le faire
alors je les conduis
là il est allé se plaindre à ma belle
mère et à mon beau père mais après c'est
moi qui le suis fait gronder
vous savez les gens france elle s'y
prendre
c'était une des toutes dernières fois
que les comptes
voici donc comment la famille s'y est
pris pour donner le trône à l'enfant
[Musique]
la mère et la grand-mère de padmanabh
ont accepté de nous rencontrer après
plusieurs semaines de négociations
depuis la mort de son mari c'est la
grand-mère qui dirige les affaires
familiales elle nous reçoit quelques
minutes dans son secrétariat privé
sylla maharani a fini par accepter le
mariage d'amour de sa fille elle attend
autre chose de son petit fils
quand le moment sera venu pour lui de se
marier je suis certaine qu'il demandera
la bénédiction de la famille avec après
il prendra sa décision il a conscience
que c'est comme cela qu'il faut faire
s ils décident d'agir librement comme
vous l'avez fait comment réagiriez-vous
toutes les deux
on verra le moment venu
[Musique]
ma réaction je serai extrêmement déçu
je sais que maintenant les temps ont
changé mais au fond de moi ce serait
très dur à accepter à moins que à
l'école brison que ça pourrait être un
mariage d'amour avec quelqu'un qui
serait suffisamment acceptable
oui je pourrais me contenter de ça
à 13 ans padmanabh a encore le temps d'y
penser quand il n'est pas en tenue
d'apparat il met une casquette et
appelle ses copains pour faire un foot
dans les jardins du palais
tu veux venir jouer au foot tout à
l'heure
vers 6 heures
voilà voilà
tout ce qu'il veut si vivre comme un
garçon de son âge dealer d'être là six
heures précises
mais ce jour là personne ne viendra
le jeune roi finira par enfourcher sa
bicyclette pour faire des ronds tout
seul sur le toit du palais
sa prison dorée
[Musique]
les festivités du mariage du prince de
kim chars atteignent leur apogée cette
nuit les noces vont être scellé
cela
ce sont vos dernières minutes de
célibataire vous êtes anxieux pas du
tout
le prince vient chercher sa femme à dos
d'éléphant
[Musique]
la mariée la voici voilées de la tête
aux pieds dans quelques instants elle va
lier son destin à jamais et renoncer à
sa liberté
tous attendent de découvrir son visage
une simple et offs et par le prince de
sa promise
[Musique]
après sept jours de cérémonies la mariée
est donné au prince elle lui appartient
désormais et les temples heures
un fils retient son voile pas question
qu'ils tombent et que son visage soit
découvert avant la nuit noces
officiellement elle quitte sa famille
pour toujours elle n'en fait plus partie
je te promets que je reviendrai te voir
papa
[Musique]
ce faste et ses rituels certains ont
choisi de s'en détacher
''j'ai l oncle de la mariée prince lui
aussi il a renoncé à ses privilèges pour
un livre aux états unis aujourd'hui
marié à une américaine son regard a
changé ce monde n'est plus le sien
c'est un monde à part sous cloche c'est
totalement en décalage avec ce qu'est
l'inde aujourd'hui
230 millions de personnes ne mangent pas
à leur faim dans ce pays
vous que ce qui se passe ce soir est
déplacé
dans une certaine mesure oui ma famille
va me détester à presque jeune dire mais
oui la sto
les maharaja s'accrochent à leurs
traditions ils en font même un business
un moyen de financer leur survie à
udaipur c'est au lit la fête qui célèbre
l'équinoxe du printemps dans les rues
enfants et adultes tout caste confondues
s'asperge de poudre de toutes les
couleurs
au palais
autre ambiance oli se fait loin des
débordements populaire et en grande
pompe pour l'occasion le prince héritier
a revêtu ses habits de cérémonie
[Musique]
c'est une cérémonie importante pour vous
oui
faut y aller là il va y avoir du monde
je sais pas on verra bien
aujourd'hui la famille royale reçoit en
son palais elle organise un dîner et
assure la mise en scène
dans le rôle principal
le prince d'udaipur en personne
les invités les voici des touristes qui
arrivent par dizaines en convoi de
voitures est ils ont payé 80 euros pour
remonter le temps en quelque sorte
[Musique]
au coeur du city palace les troupes
d'apparat sont de sortie
et ceux qui ont payé un peu plus chères
peuvent même approché le roi au plus
près
je trouve ça génial n'était jamais monté
dans un car à savoir que je recommande
c'est un excellent moyen de transport
j'étais jamais monté dans quelque chose
d'aussi vieux qui roulent encore
le maharadja en titre semble issu d'une
gravure du 16e siècle et c'est justement
ce que les touristes apprécient
comme cette australienne
que pensez vous de ces traditions c'est
un peu désuet mais
non on adore ça vraiment vous savez nous
on prête allégeance à la reine elizabeth
alors on aime tant ça
et elles deviennent l'angleterre elle
aime ça aussi
on mourait dans venir ça coûte cher mais
c'est vraiment magnifique tout le monde
devrait être là ce soir
on se sent privilégiés d'assister à cela
ça chauffe j'ai failli brûler tout le
côté gauche
[Musique]
aucun détail n'a été omis le feu dolly
est gigantesque
les danseurs bien entraînés et les
spectateurs au comble du ravissement
[Musique]
puis vient le dîner au milieu de
centaines de bougies des plats indiens
raffiné et privilège ultime la
possibilité d'échanger quelques mots
avec sa majesté
c'est incroyable de vivre ça merci
beaucoup
l'australie a longtemps été ma deuxième
patrie
oui j'ai vécu à sydney vous avez voyagé
un peu non malheureusement les hôtels
dans lesquels je travaillais prenez tout
mon temps 25 heures par jour huit jours
par semaine mais signe est une jolie oui
oui tout à fait
cette soirée rapportera 20 mille euros
des cérémonies comme celle ci les
mémoires en organise une dizaine par an
les gens en fait mais pour venir vous
voir c'est comme cela que vous adapter à
votre temps
ce qui est fascinant c'est que des gens
viennent d'assister à cette cérémonie et
s'intéresse à son histoire les gens
veulent s'immerger dans cette culture et
ses traditions et je trouve ça très bien
et vous vous tirer profit de cette
curiosité que moi
on ne peut pas dire ça comme ça
enfin chacun en pense ce qu'il veut
pendant que le fils entretient la
curiosité des touristes le père reçoit
les familles indiennes elle lui glisse
un billet dans la main signe de respect
le vieux maharaja n'a rien perdu de son
aura
au palais de kim charles à fait défini
les deux époux à rift attachés l'un à
l'autre aile derrière lui le prince
ramène son épouse à la maison
la mariée entre dans son nouveau foyer
celui de sa belle famille et dans sa
nouvelle vie maintenant qu'elle est à
l'abri elle va enfin pouvoir dévoiler
son visage
les parents du prince l'accueil avec
quelques cadeaux elle leur base les
pieds marque de respect de soumission
et puis les uns après les autres les
proches se succèdent pour la découvrir
moi aussi je veux voir ton visage
tu es jolie
la grand-mère du prince savoure son
succès c'est elle qui avait repéré
mirguet chat parmi toutes les autres
candidates à l'amour c'est moi qui les
rencontrer en premier au gujarat elle
avait de très bonnes manières
ya des gens comme ça on voit tout de
suite comment ils sont rien qu'à leur
attitude vous ne trouvez pas
c'est bon on peut lui enlever le voile
là non on paie maintenant
ça va tu te sens bien
la princesse semble un peu intimidé à 22
ans elle doit faire attention à tous ces
gestes respecter le protocole en premier
lieu gardé les yeux baissés pour ne pas
croiser le regard des hommes
[Musique]
à peine mariée mirguet chat va devoir
dès aujourd'hui assumer ses
responsabilités de princesse elle se
présente aux villageoises
elle est très belle je viens juste de
l'avoir
tout se bouscule pour apercevoir
l'heureuse élue c'est la première
apparition publique de mirguet chat
depuis son mariage
m
c'est là qu'elle va nous livrer ses
premiers mots sous surveillance
je viens d'une famille rajput donc je
suis consciente de mes devoirs et de mes
responsabilités en tant que femme rajput
et mon seul but dans la vie c'est de
répondre aux attentes de ma belle
famille
ce comment voyez vous votre avenir est
ce que vous allez travailler par exemple
je ferai tout ce qu'on me demande
quelles que soient les responsabilités
qu'on voudra bien me donner qu'à une
fausse
cinq ans d'études un master de
management mirguet chat n'est pas naïve
entourée de sa belle famille elle a bien
compris le discours qu'on attendait
d'elle conformiste et respectueux d'une
culture ancestrale
en se mariant dans la tradition d'un lg
a choisi de rentrer dans le rang
jusqu'au bout il doit lui aussi se
conformer au protocole sans doute moins
contraignant que celui de la princesse
[Musique]
un jour mon grand père m'a appelé dans
sa chambre et il m'a dit écoute tu viens
d'avoir 18 ans dans les dix prochaines
années tu vas te marier tu vas devoir
faire un choix respecter nos traditions
et notre culture ou bien renoncer à ton
nom et à ton prestige tu pourras partir
vivre ta vie à delhi et à bombay
n'importe où dans le monde nous
soutiendrons mais tu ne pourras pas tout
avoir et là j'ai compris ce que je
devais faire
un nom plutôt que la liberté dan angie a
choisi
mon cher de manger tout ce qu'on peut
souhaiter à toi et à ta femme ce sont
des enfants les enfants
tu me fais peur
[Musique]
trinquons au meilleur d'entre nous une
existence préserver dans un des pays les
plus pauvres du monde qui vénèrent
encore ses anciens voire les maharaja
vivante la coupe de fait